[Music]
this 80 000 square foot facility in
tacoma washington
has some unfinished space so along this
area here would all be
prep of parts before they go into the
enclosed paint booth it's not finished
yet obviously
tool gauge's facility was built in large
part to support boeing aircraft
hundreds and hundreds of these would go
into a single wing but now
jets sit idle as airlines have canceled
or deferred orders for hundreds of
boeing planes
the manufacturer delivered just 28
aircraft in the third quarter
this is the most significant the most
destructive event
for the entire industry 911 was
a blip on the radar screen compared to
to the effect of the pandemic thousands
have been laid off across the travel
industry
boeing alone has shed more than 19 000
workers
with further federal aid uncertain
analysts expect more layoffs in
aerospace
everybody who is anywhere around
aircraft manufacturing or maintenance
they're all feeling this but trouble
started well before the pandemic took
hold
we in the aerospace industry have maybe
been experiencing 2020 longer than 2020
has actually existed
so how much longer will 2020 last for
the industry
and as boeing's cuts and shock waves
down its supply chain
what are companies like tool gauge doing
to keep the lights on
to understand the problems facing
suppliers it's important to look first
at those facing boeing
what they do has a significant impact on
what we do
if they rate up on an aircraft we're
contractually obligated to support those
rate ups it's when the rates go down
that things get difficult so far this
year boeing has cut production rates for
some of its major aircraft
the manufacturer is now forecast to
produce around 240 planes this year
in 2019 it produced 750.
before the pandemic boeing was already
facing a crisis
two fatal crashes led to the grounding
of its 737 max in march 2019.
we didn't really know how long that
would last right we all hoped it would
last a couple of months and then it
turned into six months
and ultimately it's been longer than
that the plane's prolonged grounding
created a backlog of finished jets
prompting boeing to halt production of
the max in january
some of the jet's biggest suppliers
responded with cuts
and then we had kovid hit and everybody
stopped traveling on every type of
airplane pretty much
everywhere
passenger volumes plummeted in march as
governments put lockdowns and travel
restrictions in place
at their lowest point in april volumes
were down 95
compared with the year earlier
restrictions on international travel
heard demand for boeing's wide body
planes which are larger than the max
and they started piling up too so
suddenly
nothing was safe for the supply chain no
programs
were safe because of of of the pandemic
and its effect on the travel industry as
a whole
boeing said it's working with suppliers
on issues related to financial health
in addition the company said we are
using this downturn to refocus our
energy on safety
quality and a stable production system
for the future both within boeing
and our extended supply chain that
includes tool gauge
the company does most of its work for
boeing's wide-body aircraft
whenever you hear that noise you know
they're making something
general manager jim lee estimates at
least 75 percent of his business
is direct to boeing or its tier one
suppliers this is a part that ends up
going on to
a triple 7x engine
toolgage has been supplying boeing
aircraft for more than 40 years
we've never lost a contract with boeing
so we've always been able to renew the
contract and
and grow the statement of work so we've
actually just
built the business up year over year
over year helping tool gauge was
boeing's high production rates
particularly on the wide body 787.
prior to 2020 the aerospace industry
faced a production surge
and it was being labeled by analysts as
this super cycle
at the start of the year boeing was
producing 14 787s and five triple sevens
per month
it also estimated the max would return
to service midway through the year
toolgage said those rates put the
company on track to double its revenue
over a three year period
so toolgage built a new factory and not
just to add space
but also to add new equipment and
technologies
that was all before the coronavirus took
hold in the u.s
we were all wondering what what the end
of the super cycle was going to be
and sometimes joking about it of what
could it take
none of us thought it would take a
global pandemic
tool gauge was forced to shut down and
in washington state we were granted
an essential status so that we could
return to work to support boeing but
it wasn't long after that that you know
the airline's not seeing traffic and
then
starting to defer orders and and then it
just got worse month over month over
month
soon after boeing cut production rates
it plans to make
six 787s and two triple sevens a month
next year
meanwhile a planned production increase
for the max which restarted limited
production in may
was delayed until 2022 then we jumped
into
the painful process of determining which
of the people do we keep it wasn't
who do we let go it was like who do we
keep and how do we keep
this business viable based on the rate
that we see now
in june toolgate laid off staff going
from nearly 190 employees
to about 80. it was a very
difficult and challenging situation i
think for everybody
tarasita kiros has been working for tool
gauge for more than two years
since the layoffs she said many in the
company have assumed multiple roles
before i used to basically focus on what
is a scheduling
and the planning of production
so now i help out directly with customer
service
and the other departments that is
assembly and machining
there used to be people to do that
before toolgage also cut its shifts due
to the rate decrease
going from three eight-hour shifts per
day to one 10-hour one
the business is now closed on fridays
but there is reason for optimism
kiros and lee both say it appears the
worst is behind them
we're starting to ramp up again slowly
and we're not hiring new people but
we're rehiring the people that got laid
off
one reason for that is the pending
return to service of the max
the other a return to travel especially
when a coronavirus vaccine
likely becomes available for those
suppliers who
are able to be creative enough and
flexible enough
and hold on if they can make it through
the next six months to two years
they will be in a strong position to
respond to an uptick
the eventual uptick in the market that
is going to happen
the thing that is a little bit unknown
is you know what does that mean to those
airplanes that are currently grounded
how do they return to service when does
that trigger
replacement aircraft orders and then of
course how does that affect
new aircraft production lee estimates it
will be another year and a half to two
years before the industry gets back to
pre-covered production rates
until then he says the company might
defer some investments it planned to
make in the new facility
it will also seek out complementary work
outside of commercial aerospace
the thing that's going to be missing is
if you looked at our curve for growth it
looked something like this right
it was a pretty steep climb on our
revenue growth and you know we had the
factory to support it
but if you look at it now it goes it's
pretty flat for the next two years and
then it starts to go back up where
where we'd hope some analysts say that's
too optimistic
i don't anticipate a return to
production rate
until 2024 and we don't really
in my opinion recover
from this pandemic and from the impact
on air travel probably not until the end
of this decade
boeing said as we stand today we project
it will take about three years for
travel to return to 2019 levels
and it will be a few years beyond that
for the industry to return to long-term
trend growth
in its recent annual market forecast
boeing said the coronavirus pandemic
will reduce global jetliner demand by
around 2000 planes over the next decade
ultimately boeing and its suppliers are
at the whim of a virus without an end
date with fears of a second wave in the
u.s
and drug makers getting closer to a
vaccine the future
is unclear the game that we're playing
in aerospace is not a short game it's a
long game
and the investments take a little bit
longer
to to pay off but
[Music]
but i think we're going to be fine